in our series school matters we're
highlighting a problem plaguing many
schools bullying nearly half of children
in grades 4 through 12 reported being
bullied in school at least once in the
past month and nearly a third of
students admitted to bullying others in
the same time frame
Mickey fatties shows how one New Jersey
school district is tackling the problem
with virtual reality how many of you
have ever been bullied raise your hand
seventh grader Luka Maddie Ellie says
there's problems with bullies began in
elementary school I guess I'm not
respected towards them because they're
all cool kids and they got their bigshot
stuff and I'm not I'm just
boring boring on me who know boring I
just met you like boring to this sense
where I'm not the greatest soccer player
that they've ever known that I was
always picked last during gym I think
it's on the side we were there as Maddie
Ellie and his classmates there's jack
watch this 360 degree video made by
their eighth-grade peers for the first
time no one likes you through virtual
reality this stinks the students show
each other what it feels like to be
excluded from activities like basketball
sometimes you do go through it and it's
the best middle school it's a part of it
we needed a way to convey to those
peoples if you knew what this felt like
you might not do it Michael Savino the
superintendent of the Springfield School
District introduced virtual reality
technology into the curriculum last year
what's the ultimate goal with the
virtual reality videos to open up to as
many young people and adults as we can
the serious and long-range impact of
being mean-spirited just to satisfy
yourself and that in the end your
satisfaction is fleeting and those
people are suffering Davina was driven
in part by New Jersey college student
Tyler Clementi who died by suicide in
2011 the tragedy spawned statewide
anti-bullying legislation but divino
says it doesn't go far enough it's
essentially become a reporting law
doesn't really address the underlying
problems that lead to harassment
intimidation and bullying so he teamed
up with kin full a company that teaches
social-emotional learning by using
virtual reality to recreate real-life
scenarios like the cyberbullying Erica
Carey faced in high school so it's
easier to hide behind a phone Kari says
her peers picked on her because she had
a lot of guy friends there would always
be some sort of slut-shaming what was
the lowest point that you hit what did
that feel like I think there was one
point where I just like did not when I
even go out of my room at home now a
college freshman she hopes this
experiment breaks through to both
students and parents I want them to take
away that we have to think about the how
the bully is feeling and that they do
have an insecurity and that we should be
nicer to them as well I think most
people would be surprised to hear you
saying that about a bully yeah we kind
of glaze over that when talking about
bullying about going to a new school so
calm down and be confident high school
freshman Morgan Blair hopes her video
impacts others and reminds them how much
words can hurt in the one word I don't
like always comes up in every
conversation so I keep that word so I
used that I had to show people how it
feels to be in my shoes if they had to
for one day so from this video I want
you guys to take away that racism still
exist no matter what we think
and she says learning to forgive has
helped her heal but the scars will never
entirely fade it's like a birthmark it
can't always be covered up but it's
always just going to be there with you
but at the end of the day it makes you
stronger as a person stronger for the
experience of seeing through someone
else's eyes for CBS this morning
Niki batiste Springfield New Jersey
sounds like an education and empathy
yeah there's a great program